a long journey finally comes to an end
as a cat found thousands of miles away
from home is now back with her owner
Victoria Saha joining us with the
conclusion of Raven's Adventure
I received about 100 emails from eight
news now viewers and dozens of phone
calls too wanting to help Raven go home
we asked and you delivered
I could not sleep I am just ready to get
her back Tracy cost is waiting for a
special passenger I'm just so ready to
see her y'all don't have a clue she's
waiting here at the Birmingham airport
for a family member she never thought
she would see again until we found out
she was in Vegas I had still been going
out and calling for her
there was no way raven could hear her
calling
because she was in Las Vegas we brought
her over to PetSmart and had her scanned
and they said
she's got a chip but it's from Alabama
Raven walked away from her Alabama home
more than two years ago no one knows how
she got here are you waiting for
somebody
but now Raven's journey is over right
right
[Music]
come here
I miss you sweetheart oh I can't believe
I got her back years of Hope coming true
for cost I'm so happy Raven's return was
made possible by a host of volunteers
including a non-profit group called
imagine home two days after our story
aired there were enough donations to buy
Raven's flight home I wish raven could
talk so she could tell me what she's
been through and how she got to Vegas
with Raven now back in her mom's arms
it's clear she knows she's home I think
she feels comfortable now that she's
back with her mama
oh what a wonderful ending to that story
I love her reaction too and you see that
hug I mean they're waiting a while for
that one I think you need to write a
children's book about this I might I
might The Adventures of Raven I know and
it's all thanks to the scan right the
microchip is so important even Tracy
said she would have never gotten Raven
back but we also do want to give a shout
out to Hearts Alive Village here in Las
Vegas because they actually open their
doors after hours on a Sunday yeah to
get raven medically cleared in order to
fly a lot of people working together to
make it happen thank you Las Vegas as
always right thanks Victoria I'll be
honest I think Raven's gonna come back
to Vegas
this is
Perry over there it ended well she's
staying with Mom